[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIA LALLA-MAHARAJH: I'm losing track of
the days, and yet another
incredible day for female genital mutilation.
It's not often you hear that phrase.
Melinda Gates, I managed to corner her as
she was leaving the building,
had a very quick chat.
And she's also promised to follow up through
the Gates Foundation.
>> Why don't you give us your card and see
if maybe Gabriel can make
sure we follow up?
JULIA LALLA-MAHARAJH: And our very own David
Cameron from the UK, the
leader of the Conservative Party.
I was pleased to hear that he knew about it.
>> It's something that actually is effecting,
you know, families and
people in the UK as well as in parts of Africa
and elsewhere.
So it is a subject we take extremely seriously.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIA LALLA-MAHARAJH: And a really important
meeting for me today was
very briefly to be introduced to the President
of Senegal.
[PAUSE]
JULIA LALLA-MAHARAJH: Had a really great meeting
this morning with
Kathy Calvin from the UN Foundation.
This is a very specific foundation that looks
at women and child
health.
>>It's time we really made this a high priority.
And help all those 140 million women who have
already been victims, and
change the culture for the girls in the future.
JULIA LALLA-MAHARAJH: We had a great meeting
with the Minister of
Finance from Rwanda.
And it was very heartening to hear his words
about women's empowerment
and the role of women in his society.
[PAUSE]
JULIA LALLA-MAHARAJH: We also spoke with William
Haag.
>> I think this is the way to do it, by the
way, what you're doing.
Because you now can, through multi-media,
raise all kinds of issues that parliaments
haven't discussed adequately.
JULIA LALLA-MAHARAJH: The President of the
International Labor
Organization.
>> Now, let me first congratulate you.
It's not easy to get here and to be understood
in terms of what you're
trying to do.
I think that if any cause is legitimate it
is yours.
JULIA LALLA-MAHARAJH: You may remember I said
this issue has to move
out of the margins.
And what I feel today is that all these different
pieces are coming
together in a way that's really going to allow
me to follow up and
hopefully make sustainable change.
[MUSIC PLAYING]